10 years 15 people recommending this
book especially you willem dafoe you
know who you are
i never thought my expectations could be
surpassed and guess what green eggs and
ham
did that not only did it surpass all of
my expectations and hopes and dreams and
ideals and everything that i hoped and
love and dream
and have ideals about it literally
murdered me i'm dead i don't exist i'm i
actually
i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] dead i died
i'm actually i'm dead i don't i'm dead
i died so my expectations were high okay
well defoe kept telling me you gotta
read this book let me first
give you an idea of what it's like to
read this book no spoilers purely in
gif format so uh get jiff
gif gift format
[Music]
hey hey look at the gifts
[Music]
i like that one i will die for sam
i am he's not your typical protagonist
he
is uh subverting so many tropes i'm
converted i never thought i could be a
dr seuss fan
i just thought that was a made-up name
like dr dre now that i'm like
totally on board the seuss train i may
even branch out and check out the other
universes the captain hat universes the
the yard of the turtle
journal the turtle universes i'm still
new to all this if you read this book
you will die it will change your life
so rating three out of five stars the
bfg was better
[Music]